ça allez hop c'est cadré on va attendre
deux petites minutes pour voir si c'est
bien parti ouvrir le chat pour être bien
mais normalement on est parti pour pour
une heure de bli pour une heure et demie
de bli on va faire débits sont un petit
peu joué alors je vais ouvrir hop le
stream est parti est ok donc ça c'est
parti et lui je vais en profiter pour
pour vous mettre le lien vers la vidéo
du match je mette ça là
je vais mettre ça là donc ça va être
ouvert et juste vérifier qu'ils soient
bien ouvert de partout et ouvrir les
deux les bons chat est comme ça qu'on
pourra partir tranquille au hockey donc
on est paré pour l'on passe sur le tce
tv bon c'est pas grave c'est pas grave
c'est pas grave c'est pas grave du tout
je vais en profiter pour faire un petit
truc et on va santé has et chats qui est
là juste mettre en ligne le le speech
est en fait ce que je n'ai pas fait ce
que je voulais faire et comme ça on va
on va partir mais ça je mettrai le lien
comme ça on va on va être bien et on va
se lancer en même temps sur les autres
je vois quoi et qu'il ya des gens qui
arrivent dans le chat et j'ai un peu
vite c'est ce soir et alors mais j'ai un
peu discuté avec vous moi je sais qu'à
pas grand canton fait sur twitter par
rapport à youtube dans la communauté
quand même on va en profiter puisque en
fait demain je vais vers paris et je
vais voir un invité de marque en fête ce
week end et donc j'ai discuté de ça avec
vous
karlsson grichting on va être bon on va
ouvrir on va envoyer ça comme ça on va
être comme ça on va être royal
comme ça on va être royal
on peut glisser voilà nickel comme ça
c'est fait ok donc il ya carlson rue il
ya polisy salut pour un tronc il ya quoi
ce soir j'ai un bout que les choses a
fait plaise le live en direct sur white
witch tv tfc cheikh comme fabula vidéo
avec laurent c'est génial 17 chars n
était pas mal invité de marque elle
marque non alors oui alors bon alors je
vais discuter un peu avec le chat je
vais voir j'ai vérifié mon blog font
plus on joue un grand maître direct sur
une chaise comme tv est ce que ces
nouveaux j'en sais rien on va vous dire
pour moi je ne sais pas je vais garder
le chat de twitch et on va essayer de
jouer tranquille où donc pas donc vivre
laurent et en plus se voyait prochain
coup peut-être qu'on aura encore mieux
que laurent pas mieux je ne parle pas
d'un point de vue commentaires ce que
laurent a été juste excellent et c'est
difficile de faire mieux que laurent je
pense que là on est en train de on
atteint des sommets mais
mais mieux au niveau est le mieux classé
au classement elo du coup du coup on
peut on peut espérer ni à ce niveau là
encore je crois que c'est le seule chose
qu'on puisse faire
je vois que je la galaure que je l'avais
pas du tout qu'est ce qui se passe
qu'est ce qui se passe avec ma connexion
internet
on va fermer ça pour voir ce que ça
donne
pourquoi est-ce que ça lag
je ne comprends pas c'est comme s'il y
avait un truc couvert chez moi qui
bloque ma connexion qu'est ce que c'est
que soient fouillés qu'est ce que c'est
que ce bazar bon la partie on n'est pas
du tout concentré et je vais faire petit
rock
je vais pas en à fond dans l'esprit
regarde comment ça tu dis qu'on est on
est live aussi à thiès comme t'es ok
nickel et ma collection suis en train de
voir qui est en train de revenir
alors je sais pas une pub qu'on a ouvert
je sais pas ce qui s'est ouvert en tout
cas ça craignait
oui un trousses 15 secondes et j'ai tout
à fait vu il ya eu un trou de 15
secondes il ya eu un trou de 15 secondes
tout bêtement on ne sait pas pourquoi
bon alors il va falloir qu'on a eue le
maté à l'ancienne
de toute façon c'est ce qu'on sait faire
alors pour mater à l'ancienne comment on
fait ok donc son idée en fait c'est que
j'ai plus je peux plus sacrifiés sur sur
détroit quand je perds fou prend des 3
il me fait pions prends et je lui prend
b3 ok ça risque de défendre pour lui
quand même donc on va faire ça
feeder qui nous demandent comment ça va
mais je pense qu'il est mieux à faire
enfin il y avait peut-être à 5 et
peut-être cavaliers à 4 qui était bien
il y avait autre chose à faire ce que
l'on fait on va faire céder et ça va lui
permettre sur cavaliers prend de ramener
des pièces en défense on n'aime pas du
tout la manière dont je mène cette
attaque et en plus il commence par fou
ici en plus il commence par fou ici ce
que je n'avais pas vu et si on prend b3
en prend aux deux ça n'a pas marché on
va prendre ici encore d'affaires d'amd 4
comme ça si fait cavalier français 6 du
fait d'armes prend ici
ah oui mais prend comme ça bon mais
comme vous voyez entre la connexion le
truc le machin c'était pas facile
quel délire attaque la dame madame se
sont enfermés mais le hockey c'est une
partie à oublier trop de problèmes
techniques pour une seule partie on va
abandonner tout bêtement arrivé
tellement mieux à faire et je vais
reprendre le chat alors sécurité voyez
donc bon j'en étais ou alors oui je
racontais qui en fait demain je vais
vers paris je pars vers paris et donc je
m'arrêterai un jour à paris je vais
aller boire aller voir des bd des coups
des coups à paris demain soir est en
fait après donc samedi dimanche je vais
chehab sol
donc ça va être assez sympa on va
rencontrer âme au sol voire plus que ce
que ça donne
on essaiera je pense de faire deux trois
vidéos dont je pas exactement ce qu'on
va faire mais on serait pas on ne sait
pas c'est pas encore dit exactement ça
allait faire comme comme vidéo on va
filmer deux trois trucs et ça va être ce
mettre sympa ça va être assez sympa donc
je pars demain matin à 7h30 de chez moi
et il habite de l'autre côté de la
france donc ça va mettre un certain
temps avant d'arriver chez lui c'est
pour ça qu'ils font un petit stop à
paris sur le chemin avant de avant
d'aller chez lui en plus faire un
changement de gare
j'arrive à une garde je repars à une
autre tadjau avec kafka clairement donné
quand même genre pions prend un f4 prend
10 une fois on va faire f 4 on va faire
cavalier f3 vous faut pas laisser faut
pas laisser trop s'approcher du roi est
en train de faire de la merde quand même
là je pense au ketchup qui a aidé car tu
vas faire juger si je pousse à hk ratera
les faut être un peu dans l'esprit là
quand est-ce que je viens sur agen et
c'est vrai que je profite de venir sur
agen pendant qu'ils sont encore au top
en top 14 à y voir g6 y ont encore
largué une pièce non mais j'arrive pas à
me concentrer ce soir j'ai pas le j'ai
pas du tout mojo de la concentration
pour nos échecs graphique et j'ai 6 kg 4
mais voilà quand je vois pas ce genre de
truc à tempo ça vraiment dire que c'est
la cata il va quand même réussir à
m'enfermer et je vais faire quelques
cheveux et je vais revenir vers f3 voilà
il sacrifie ok il va récupérer le
cavalier range étroit et on va être
complètement foutu mais comme je vous
disais l'ag s'est pas c'est pas du tout
la concentration
ok on va faire dame de on va essayer
d'aller contre attaquer comme on peut
mais en fait on peut pas contre attaque
et on peut rien faire on est vraiment
dans la merde j'ai vraiment très mal
jouer une nouvelle fois à faire flamber
5 à essayer de s'en prendre aux cavale
pour essayer de gratter des cases qu'il
prend bon bah je prends du pillon toute
façon j'ai pas trop le choix
ok mais dame prend 1,5 ces échecs il m'a
l'air d'être aussi nul que moi quand
même je pense qu'on a affaire à un duel
de deux nuls
quand même très très mal joué c'est
fantastique vous êtes en train en train
de voir des mecs franchement quand vous
voyez les lots vous vous dites ya un
problème
les deux sont quand même sacrément nul
ça va les deux sont quand même sacrément
nul alors lequel est le plus nul des
deux est ce que c'était df pantani est
ce que c'est blitz crime
c'est une question qu'on est en droit de
se poser mais je pense que c'est
vraiment la question c'est vraiment la
question du jour est ce que y en a un
qui est plus fort que l'autre ou est-ce
que les deux sont à peu près du même
niveau au final bon alors là je vais
faire d'armes 7 il va faire dame ces
deux je vais faire 3 écoutez ça me
paraît pas mal ça me paraît pas mal
sinon je lui fait rage si on m'a l'air
pas mal du tout on va faire 3 1 comme
prévu et on va les prendre le truc on va
voir la dame en e3 elle sera pas mal
placé mais vraiment c'est vraiment un
niveau de jeu mais c'est tellement ça
joue tellement mal à l'étuvée faire g6
ah non je les dames projet cinq ans
maintenant mais comment tu vois pas qui
a une presse
on est vraiment nul on est vraiment mais
super nul et le mec ne le voit pas le
niveau de jeu non mais c'est juste une
honte quoi j'ai quasiment honte de faire
ce stream faut agir c'est quand même de
la fin j'ai même pas les mots c'est
tellement pourri ça joue tellement mal
quelque part c'est beau quelque part
c'est beau bon la fougue 4 quand même je
suis un peu ressaisi pour le mec avant
donne mais c'est fantastique c'est
fantastique c'est enfin voila si vous
enlevez 1000 points aux deux là je pense
qu'on est dans le ton franchement 2005
c'est quand même un peu bien un peu trop
bien payé vu ce que ça donne
là les mecs moi je ne vois pas la prise
en main il ne la voit pas il me la
redonne je finis par la voir à terme à
la fin je ne sais pas je vais faire ces
trois trains directs
j'innove d'un couple mixte
c'est un coût qui se battirent affaire
d'âme ses deux protégés blitz au rsa pch
a assez lassé de ses beats dans l'esprit
à fond sert que les mecs sont tellement
dans l'esprit que qui ne sont même plus
capables de voir continuer cette emprise
très déstabilisant vert j'espère que ça
vous fait plaisir devant votre écran
vous voyez que ben nous aussi on est en
mauvaise forme et on dit qu'il faut deux
joueurs pour faire une bonne partie bien
il faut quand même deux joueurs ensemble
pour faire une partie de merde grecque
elles ont atteint des sommets
franchement on atteint des sommets c'est
beau c'est beau parce que j'ai une bonne
ouverture je ne veux même plus commenter
ces partis en vous donnant départ je ne
sais même plus quoi dire
c'est tellement pourri par annoncer ça
faisait longtemps que je rêvais quand
même un de faire un stream comme ci
comme ça mais bon il faut il faut être
deux pour pour jouer dans l'esprit à
fond
on a vraiment trouvé la mort et ce qu'il
est dans l'esprit par conviction ou est
ce qu'il est dans l'esprit finalement
parce que bon il est dépassé par les
événements et l'esprit le dépasser un
peu la question qu'on se pose toutefois
un f2 on va protéger nos pions centraux
on est très contents maintien ou qui
bouge saddam bas au caire ouais bah si
tu bouges et adam boulton enfin je fais
ce que tu veux
bon bah on va on va faire moins bien
pour le moment écoutez ça a l'air d'être
trop compliqué sinon
cette partie l'air d'être trop compliqué
pour moi je faire cavalier ces cas on
peut provoquer des choses
ok ok ok
le frange et trois chez pas je sens bien
d'avoir mon fou en face de saddam peut
pas être mal placée ce fou je me suis là
ici ça chez ea découpe le roi ou que le
roi pas s'il est bien quoi le roi ne
peut pas aller en g8 puisqu'il ne peut
pas évoquer de l'autre côté il découpe
on va découper de ce côté là j'ai des
fous qui regarde vers ton et droits
personnels d'un pardon on ne te laisses
par ok on va quand même ouvrir la
position maintenant au nom n'est pas mal
parce qu'on va ouvrir mais je pense pas
que le mec plus depuis joué aussi mal
pendant aussi longtemps c'est pas
possible va se réveiller un jour
ok je vais prendre du fou ce qui peut
paraître bizarre mais lorsque je jouais
l'écart ayant f5 et en fait je veux
découper le roi quoi vous faites une
europe crapa quoi tu ne rock rapaces un
peu le leitmotiv de la partie mais je ne
veux pas te laisser rauque et je mets à
tour en f1 pour pour être sûr que tu ne
manqueras pas ok maintenant je vais
fêter à lyon au cices
il va faire touré tour quelques pas
j'ai pas j'arrive pas à calculer c'est
horrible on va prendre une fois en fait
ya ce truc là qui peut rester en prise
j'arrive pas à faire la rendre utile le
fou aussi c'est un peu de la merde on va
faire dame b 3 à la limite même s'il
encaisse je me barre ouais mais il
encaisse pas à faire flouer 5
on va reprendre du pillon vous poussez
le truc angers 4 il faut toujours par ok
mais bon à la limite est ce que c'est si
grave je vais protéger on a plus de
temps parce que
le niveau des partis a été tel jusqu'à
maintenant que le fait que personne n'a
encore donné pièce c'est vrai que ça me
déstabilise un petit peu on a vraiment
plu temps là bon on va aller encaisser
le pion
ok il va faire ça quand on a monté le
roi pour le moment je pense que ça donne
je pense il joue juste vite ça peut
éventuellement suffire bon je montre le
roi je prépare ma finale je pousse les
pions tiens je compte le relancer 4
c'est dangereux de monter durant ces 4 1
c'est complètement débile mais ok c'est
dans le ton tiens un petit échec
on va passer
non non non vous j avais d'am dam de 5
da da dam attendre d'ailleurs il a
manqué tout reprend g4 peut-être ok on
va proposer nul
ok on a réussi à faire du loup et je
pense qu'il a raté je pense qu'il a raté
tout reprend g4 je faisais dame ranger 4
il faisait dam des cinq matches il a
raté ça bon ça a joué très mal mais on
s'en est sorti bon qu'est ce qu'on va
réussir à faire encore enfin si celui-ci
ce mec là ne joue pas trop mal
ça sent la grosse catastrophe ou là des
cartes les mecs et dans l'esprit à fond
à cinq je ne te laisse pas être dans
l'esprit je te bloque directement quoi
mais que ces deux jours une orang-outan
ouais mais bon du coup il a pris part à
l'espace manquait de fer bsi sous les 7
éventuellement me bloquer quelques fous
pranger 2 je pense
je pas si sûr de moi mais bon on est le
camion c5 ça permettra d'éviter toutes
les bêtises en protégeant sa ok il mais
ce truc là ici donc maintenant je mette
ce cavalier laon 17 l'autre ont aussi
ses pions f5
on va essayer un truc comme ça on va
faire passer celui-là la vallée on va
faire un truc artistique est notre
allait assez faiblard hongrie prend à m
cavagnan eux sans voix les visées des 3
qu'est ce que c'est que cette partie je
ne comprends rien je ne vois rien je ne
comprends rien que se passe-t-il cas ce
qui se passe en d3 ça c'était sûrement
je mette en b 4 je veux tournicoti
tournicoton quoi il me fait damas deux
je fais qu'aller à 4 tournicoti
tournicoton après je lui prends ça je
lui prends ça et je place cavaliers
c'est 2 à la fin je fais une fourchette
à oka j'aime bien qui a et b 4 je
m'approche serait ok tu prends bon bah
je te prends je suis très heureux je
t'ai pris ton fou de cases noires
tombons fou oui mais je te prends ici tu
prend du plomb je te prends ici tu
prends et je prends ok tu prends de la
dame
mais ok tu as pris de la
tiens j'avais pas vu un ok il a pris de
la dame
ok admettons pas de mettons admettons
qu'elle est catastrophe de pas voir
celui qui pouvait prendre de la dame
mais qu'est-ce que je suis mauvais
hockey
l'inca prix de la dame ok on va en
profiter pour faire du tour à trois
dames à 8
c'est une idée que je vais faire thaler
vous pouvez retrouver ça dans l'airé ti
c'est pour eux la dame double action
quoi je suis en a huit je suis hors jeu
mais en fait je contrôle le centre je
t'attaque à 2 en fait je suis très
heureux avec madame et aux caisses il
fait dame b2 pour protéger je suis très
heureux parce que du coup ça d'ammal
place et je lui faire du tour 8 je l ai
vu taper sans doute puis on ferme on
verra monter tours b 1 pas trop à quoi
ça sert pour moi de façon je vois un
pion je prends toujours égalité
matérielle au caisson quatre ans et six
filles illusion mais pour le moment je
n'y touche pas je ne mange pas de ce
pain je le prends quand je veux vraiment
il vient en jeu le contrôle matour en
1/8 bien placé ok maintenant je te fais
tour ces deux je veux rentrer avec
madame hockey suffrages 5h je m'en fiche
totalement ok il vient comme ça et bien
je viens en c3 hop je suis protégé par
un bon fou je suis très heureux et
maintenant je viens en rade avec madame
à aimer bon maintenant il peut me
ok c'est pas si bien s'il y en a deux en
fait il peut me faire tour en un moment
ouais mais je viendrai à eux deux ouais
tiens je vais venir on a deux en plus je
menace le pion c4 au passage c'est un
très important parce que si jean castet
4 je peux tout encaisser aucun effet eu
cinq as assez pénible du coup maintenant
il protège son qu'avec son fou et il me
ferme un peu la vue
je dirais que c'est plutôt bien joué ok
je vais revenir en c2 pour le moment ils
peuvent peut-être me faire tour là je
sais pas j'y comprends rien c'est trop
compliqué pour moi mais bon je veux
faire tout reprend m 2 mais j'aurais dû
prendre en c6 plutôt en fait j'ai voulu
jouer au malin et puis finalement ne
joue pas mal hein quand tu vois rien
quoi mais là j'ai placé sa tour ans ce
qui veut dire qu'il peut se faire ouais
mais bon ok je dois prendre ce que sinon
il ya 17 et maintenant il fait tour à
c'est très bien joué du coup je prends
une fois il prend et je vais mettre ma
tour en fuite
mais du coup je suis même pas mieux du
coup je suis même pas mieux
bon j'ai très très très très très mal
joué à quoi ça sert de faire ça mais là
encore c'est une très mauvaise je ne
prends que des mauvaises décisions
quassam d'horreur
j'essaie de faire avec vos rêves de
succès que joue encore pour gagner alors
que on va prendre
et puis maintenant c'est nul ok mais
quelle partie horrible mais qu'un
proposé nul maintenant on est obligé de
faire nul je veux tu attaques et
confions au revoir on va essayer de
l'avoir à l'usure
on va essayer de faire le truc le plus
dégueu du monde non ok on n'aura pas
réussi ok maintenant c'est une union va
lui proposer
on a essayé de pas être fair play win et
j'avais forcément des trucs quand même
bien ça va vraiment mal mais le truc
rassurant c'est qu'on joue très mal et
qu'on est à 25 22 j'ai envie de dire ça
rassure tout le monde dans le chat a
aimé dans le châssis fou si même lui et
25-22 tout le monde peut l'être quoi
sert à faire qualifier trois patrons
intérêt de ce coup mais hop on va jouer
comme ça je connais tu joues avec grand
roque
bon bon bon bon je vais reculer le fou
j'ai le même temps j'ai trois façons
s'il veut à jouer avec fougue et c'est
comme ça je serai bien rock et que je
veux comme ça on va faire food et 3 on
va se développer avec lecavalier a eu
deux on va te chasse et on fout ou là
mais attendez la question c'est fou
prendre des huit qui prend des deux mais
je repars en fait enfin je me barre je
reviens en h4
comment est-ce que ton cas banier sort
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai pas vu parce
que là pour moi le cavalier si vous
voulez ah oui ok il ya cette tactique
ok ça j'avais pas vu ok mais ça c'était
très chaud à voir qu'ils avaient des
cinq ans sortie de truquer que et qui
règle récupérer la case de quatre pour
son cavalier mais ça honnêtement j'étais
très loin de le voir ce truc là on va
faire qui avaient lieu deux pour le même
pas on va prendre ça j'étais très loin
de le voir il a vu tellement vite
faisons à calais prend le cas tout cas
il avoué en 5 secondes of beaucoup trop
fort
n'ai-je pas sûr qu'il ait vu des cinq de
base quand même enfin m'ont chassé sont
fous là on va mettre ça là on va se
cacher avec le roi découvrir le pion g2
elle valait à 5 c'était pas super super
bien inspiré je pense aux quais et b5
non plus on s'appelle pas top top je
pense que c'est une assez mauvaise
partie poursuit même complètement sur
surface tour des scènes je fais fouache
cet échec et puis on en parle le plus
bon ok mais chez cavalli ces sept là
qu'est ce que je vois pas marqué mais je
prends ouais je me paraît que le roi je
ne veux pas me prendre des chèques cette
partie ne m'intéresse pas ça dégage
je vais matourin je te fais fouet 5 je
t'échange les pièces je ne veux plus te
voir ça ne m'intéresse pas qu'un dégage
mais non dégage encore ce jeune homme et
je veux changer les pièces
je ne suis plus du tout intéressé par
toutes ces pièces sur l'échiquier ça
n'intéresse plus j'ai plus de matériel
que toi je veux tout est changé
viens on met le fond c3 c3 attention et
un piège mais aux caisses qui menacent
quelque chose dont je ne vois pas bien
dégagé avec ton fou
on écoute et les loulous allez je sais
que je vois rien mais j'ai envie de vous
la faire le grand je vais envie de vous
faire le grand spectacle
je vais prendre effet retour des 8 je
veux faire food et 6 et ooshop et on
fout ok mais là dessus je te fais des
quatre et sur bessin je te fais food et
4 améliore à tour des six à ça va pas
marcher
donc on va faire ses 4 je suis pas sûr
que ça marche mais je veux faire le
grand jeu food et cissokho bon je sais
pas s'il a bien défendu
ben là c'est complètement nul ce qu'il
est en train de faire il fait rage et
celle du fait ça je les change des tours
non mais ok mais c'est face c'est une
honte le niveau de jeu ce soir
je comprends pas ce qui se passera en et
25 30 mais c'est absolument n'importe
quoi
c'est absolument n'importe quoi mon
record sur votre chaise comme ces 25 50
mais je jouais très bien du jour je
jouais à 25 50 ou j'avais obtenu 25 50
fin là c'est complètement ont tout ce
qui est en train de se passer
on est en train de très mal joué enfin
le juge je comprends pas ce qui se passe
bon allez prendre ces 5 enfin je vais
récupérer un pion à la rigueur si tu
veux bon je laisse venir
ok il veut jouer il veut jouer et quatre
mâles empêcher
en fait je suis pas sûr que saddam et
grand intérêt en h6 en fait je vais
faire dame à cinq je vais faire flouer
f5
je pense pas qu'il puisse prendre ici
quand même c'est un peu too much
donc j'ai cas j'avais pas vu je dois
avouer manqué de venir en russie ce cas
l'importance foulée cinq échecs c'est
hyper pénible donc et il ne le fait pas
bon on va faire le grand roque
ok on est quand même assez mal à la
sortie de cette ouverture
superman week end là
c'est pas comme si c'était la première
fois mais là du coup sans le fou de
cases marche pas trop quoi faire un truc
c'est qu'il va me faire cavalier des
quatre hockey le mieux que je puisse
faire c'est partir avec le roi il fait
qu'il y ait des cats je plante le fond
ces huit jeux mais le roi là bas et
comme ça je mets le roi là mais le fou
ans et vitus trésor au moins le fou me
gêne plus est ok si on fait un truc
comme ça et du cavale b 5 bat ok je
couvrirai je couvrirai bon ok mec va
attaquer l'anjou et ce à la fois je veux
faire 5
bon ok je te fais 5 ha non je ne peux
pas mais je fais cavaliers ou six je
couvre je couvre tout fait aux cinq ça
n'est pas du tout de ma jun bien cesser
complètement artificiel ce que je fais
tout à l'heure c'est complètement pourri
ok j'avais menacé ça ici prendre un je
prends ça va on va prétendre que ça va
ok tu viens avec ton cavaliers jeunes et
change rien
pas un poil dangereux mais pk tu ne peux
pas iliad à me prends à 3 sur hs1 ok moi
je prends une fois je ne touche à rien
maintenant faut que je trouve un truc à
faire
j'ai juste aucune idée d'un coup que je
peux jouer quoi c'est horrible
je vais revenir avec le fou réussi du
match local et en 17 mai j'ai plus de
temps
grass valley verbe et si c'est la barre
et faut jouer vite un jeu hyper vite
partir de maintenant à 30 secondes faut
aller le maté les tontons attend vous
dire qu'on va y aller on va y aller à
l'esbrouffe cif et dames bekkat on a un
peu mal
je suis pas comment on va mater ça mais
bon on a plus de pièces que j'avais plus
de temps j'aurais moins peur je me lève
pour la tenir
ok on va essayer ses traits du con tre
jeu de l'autre côté de l'échiquier
malheureusement ça va pas suffire
malheureusement ça ne va pas suffire
le problème c'est que s'il va faire une
âme ok bon c'était piètre niveau 1 les
gamins tension prévaut aux bouffées de
brume ou ne marche pas oui c'est sûr que
si tu as un prêt movie légale dans l'eau
ça va pas marcher
on va rester une autre variante de tout
à l'heure on va voir ce que ça donne
alors on va faire ça est-ce que rejouer
le même truc
oui mais ça remarche en fait son succès
je suis complètement sucre et la moquer
mais je fais avoir deux photos du
deuxième fois par le même truc quoi non
mais grâce à appuyer quand même bon je
vais tenter un truc d'un f4 je menace là
et si fait g5 à temps mais qu'est ce qui
se passe sur vous prendra suis fou ou ne
suis-je pas fou c'est un peu la question
que nous faisons mais elle a juste gagné
une pièce non vague et je ne vous mens
paraît juste
une dame de plus ok je recule avec mon
fou mais je te reprends ton cavaliers
nokia il a peut-être des idées encore je
regarde tout bizarre ce que je ressens
de ne pas pouvoir calculer donc c'est
pour ça que j'ai un peu peur de tout
mais quand même
bon ok d'armand f6 je t'attaque
maintenant je te faire [ __ ] bessin qui
au passage
je ne reprends pas ton cavaliers
ou la voir aller le rechercher parce que
qu'est ce que je suis en train je me
suis remis dans le problème tout seul
parce que le truc c'est que maintenant
il veut me faire quel point f2 lecture
dame ici à cavaliers des quatre non mais
attendez c'est abusé je perds tout seul
mais parce que je fais des trucs
artistique alain cavalier des quatre qui
est très pénible et qui gagne une pièce
alors que je pouvais simplement faire
roi prend des ans le damache aïe aïe aïe
aïe aïe aïe aïe
et du coup en fait on n'est pas super
bien
enfin cet adversaire joue quand même
super malin le niveau des partis fin je
sais pas comment ils ont 2005
je sais que moi je joue très mal là
maintenant je sens je fais pas mal de
petites fautes la tactique comme celle
qui vient de venir mais je sais pas du
tout comment il se débrouille quand même
parce que c'est quand même page au jour
c'est quand même pas jojo
aimons aller par là bas
bon va falloir faire un peu mieux que ce
qu'on fait depuis tout à l'heure alors
je mets tout cas j'ai ici ça en fait je
pense il va prendre et ça je pensais
bien qu'il allait faire ça il a essayé
de ressortir avec le fou en d6 je pense
c'est quand même c'est quand même assez
laid les parties depuis tout à l'heure
cav a lieu cinq ok comme ça on a pris ce
fou et c'est exactement ce que je
voulais faire comme ça je vais ramener
la tour en h7 et je vais le vice est
maintenant qu ils habitent tous les
pions sur blanc le fait d'échanger son
fou de cases blanches c'est une très
mauvaise idée
surtout qu'à soir pardon et du coup en
lui prenant le fou de cases noires on a
réussi à maintenir le niveau or je
verrai si de 2,2 d'ouvrir le check point
comme geste comme tv cinaps tv est ce
que twitter en fait s'agir le sens que
c'est ça qui a tout fait bugger j'espère
que je vais voir plus avant les
prochaines je suis vraiment vraiment
désolé c'est un truc que je qui il est
difficile de contrôler je veux dire par
là sont allés stream c'est hyper
difficile de contrôler quand on joue
bien ou quand on joue mal on peut pas le
savoir en avance mais là aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment la cata
qu'elles sont écrits dans le chat il
faut la cuisson paramètres un an
réglages paramètres un truc comme ça tu
peut activer que tu peut activer les
prêts move alors on joue contre winston
churchill 54 à les boums g4 gambie
chinois bout tu dégages
c'est le gambit chinois très intéressant
g4 deuxième tueur retarde la grotte mais
tu l'as fait quand même au deuxième coup
bon ok je fais ça bon bon bon bon que
que se passe-t-il ouais je retarde la
prise yuv apprend-t-on pions
bon ok je vais mettre mon four en g2
j'ai très heureux je faire dame b 3 je
n'avais pas du tout envie de me faire
prendre dans ces cas depuis tout à
l'heure et qui me protège qui me protège
le truc avec b5
enfin qu'est si jamais le fond et 100 km
le cavalier en 17 et je ferai fou des
cistes non mais veut faire qui avait b6
machin on va faire piéger 5 pour
commencer si fâché je fais kf3 ok mais
tu le four us voyages met le x e 5 vous
assis fait ça je fais ça ok il protège
je vais faire c'est 5
je vais menacé food et 6 je change de
plan je ferme le jeu
je suis très content de ces 5 l et
d'autres complètement dégoûté la mer
écoeuré par le coup c'est simple non je
n'y avais pas pensé ah tiens ben
maintenant je vais te faire
non je peux pas trop le faire je lui
fais retour en âge c'est une affaire
d'âme projet sain qui protège tous et si
je fais fou prend là il va reprendre et
attend c'est pas idiot ce qui vient de
faire
fait cavalier prend h ça tu fais faut
prendre 5 du fait qu on prend bon bon
bon bon bon je ne suis pas sûr mais je
vais essayer
j'ai fait ça à ça j'avais pas vu du tout
s'agit pas du tout pensé
bon allez je vais tenter de jouer dans
l'esprit mais je pense pas que ce soit
bon en fait je voulais tout faire péter
de partout faire sauter des 5
enfin j'ai l'impression que c'est pas
mon truc c'est que j'ai pas le temps de
faire cavalier avec six échecs
de fait qui prend des cinq ça à fond
dans l'esprit mais ça marche pas du tout
ok je farfouille leucate
mais je protège mon cavalier fait très
attention tu ne peux pas le prendre tu
est cloué mais bon j'ai plus de temps et
la position est complètement dingue mais
je suis très heureux de cette partie
surtout que je vois absolument et j'ai
vraiment l'impression de parent chirac
âgé quand même je veux bas mais fourcade
j'aime bien enfin c'est beau les mecs
fouet quatre c1 patoche manqué de chance
de la faire roy a chuté mon jeu reculant
de 3 tueur intéresse pas bon bah tu mets
ton fou en face du enfin ok mais le truc
c'est qu'il a une idée quand même c'est
qu'il veut pousser après on va faire ça
le truc c'est qu'il va pousser que j'ai
rien en fait tu vas faire qui
réussissent échec intermédiaire
m'apprendre prendre mais demain j'aurai
plus de temps parce qu'on fait vraiment
un truc joly sur dame prend je vais
faire cavalier e 4 en fait assez bête de
plus avoir de temps mais bon c'est beau
quoique m6 et intermédiaires
ok on va pouvoir prendre la dame
intermédiaire si jamais et sinon va
faire cavalier 4 mais on se bat on
encore la ffr d'hamelin fr dam des
quatre y apprendre à jouer grand roque
en fait françois et même mieux et sinon
on va faire d'un premier set et quasi
obligé de faire dame là on va faire dame
là ok il prend là je prends il fait ça
je prends il prend à aimer la en fait je
suis pas mieux du tout va faire des
quatre mais là ça va être juste égal
enfer où on va peut-être de même être
moins bien mais ok c'était sympa comme
parti il est peut-être mieux à faire
pour moi après une prog et je prends et
vient là ok on va faire un échec
ah mince il prend pas ça ok on va
s'approcher des pions qu'on va découvrir
non c'est pas là que tu vois là avec la
tour quelle horreur je perds un tempo
qui va me coûter cher d'ailleurs avec
mon pions bon ok je vais tout péter pion
du coût auquel on la perd
malheureusement
ah non on va pas perdre
le mec est complètement nul ils nous
laissent faire dame non mais c'est
laisser monter aujourd'hui le niveau de
jeu mais attention à ce que tu fais tu y
rencontrer cheikh je t'échange des dames
tu es obligé de prendre ces
fantastiquement nul quoi le mec n'est
pas capable d'arrêter sûr mais qu'est ce
que c'est que ce niveau là c'est
impressionnant et comme je vous dis je
sens que je joue mal mais je comprends
pas quoi 2478 quand même et là avec va
attendre une seconde pour on n'a pas
trop compris l'objectif c'est
incroyablement nul comment tu n'arrêtes
pas le pion aux fins et moi j'ai perdu
un temps qui m'a coûté cher à lui même
ne donne même pas de match quoi le
mexique non tu joues trop mal je vous
trouve bien comme toi je n'ai pas réussi
à te battre
mais c'est quand même assez prodigieux à
rester au sud 2005 aujourd'hui
bon une petite scandinave bon ok c'est
fait qu'elle ait des simples dames des 8
sinon on va juste développer un
tranquillou bon ok qu'est veux me faire
un truc avec gicam tiens je jouais cash
soit je fais jamais mes juges j'en ai
marre de me prendre du mec qui me fait
du g4 jusqu'à demain non je ne vous
laisserai plus faire là par contre c'est
un poil dangereux c'est même très
dangereux là ces niveaux de dangerosité
niveau 10 fois le mec me sacrifier en
russie ça je vous préviens tout de suite
le mec le mec c'est le mec a décidé de
prendre la cipr en prend proche du froid
et froid et futurs enjeux le tien mais
bon on va faire qui les 17
je pense y sacrifie chien toujours ici
prend du cavale moi je sais pas
bon ok là on va pas hésité très
longtemps les tontons je pense que
c'était clair pour tout le monde après
ok on va prendre sur échec et on va lui
faire le grand roque bon c'est
complètement pipeau ce sacrifice mais on
est là on est là on a fait notre
sacrifice
on a fait notre grand roque du coup il
ne peut plus nous sacrifions le site
façon le mec avait l'intention de
sacrifier un truc dans la gueule battu
dégage tu ne sacrifiera jamais il
fallait dire tu n'as parloir de
sacrifier nous ne connaissons pas et
c'est nous qui sommes là qu'on est avec
notre cahier c5 contactons caïds et 4 on
veut te faire cavalier prend fou prend
des trois a faim on est là quoi faire et
j'en suis à l'est on gagne en f3 jeu
fait qu'il prend b3 et de tu dégages
puis on prend fou prend des fois c'est
complètement à l'esbrouffe quoi ça nous
vint ce qu'on fait n'a aucun rapport a
écrit un tandem le 5
ce qu'on fait complètement débile mais
ça peut complètement marché alors
attendez je suis sûr qu'il ya un truc là
j'ai tellement envie de faire qui a aidé
sept comme ça mais bon ok j'ai envie
quand même de calculer tiens j'ai envie
de faire [ __ ] en d3 puis on prend des
trois cavaliers prend des trois chênes
base d'amd de maths états d'âme ça peut
être pas mal ça allait sur fou prend les
3 pts et ya me faire fou ici ce qui va
m'empêcher de faire marcher mon truc
je ne vois pas comment faire le beau jeu
là pour écouter les mecs ça fait des
années qu'on fait des scream on est là
pour le beau jeu on va larguer encore
une tour vous savez que ça me fait
plaisir on va aller lui sacrifiant
detroit il le mérite
ok le mec joue l échange des dames
quelle horreur quelle horreur on est
obligé d'accepter l'échangé da missive
on a encaissé sa faune ont encaissé sa
banque et c'est ça ok c'est ça et on va
revenir avec le cabba long des 3 sur
échec et ont valu poussé le pion bon
alors on en est au côté matos on a qu'à
l'âge pour pour plein de pions bon on
est mieux on est mieux mais bon c'est
pas sûr qu'on la gagne mais bon on est
très contents d'avoir réussi notre petit
tactique là d'un petit truc
petit tour de funambule on lui a fait
peur il n'existe plus non mais ok mais
de toute façon tu n'existes plus toi
quoi qu'il se passe est partie et gagner
nous avons gagné cette partie
je pensais même pas intéressant de la
jouer en fait la partie est déjà gagnée
nous l'avons emporté
on va pousser les pions a maintenant 10
pouces sont qu on fire tu ne peux faire
que ça juste assez poussé ce pion d'un
pouce le match où selon gérard est ça ne
m'intéresse pas qu'ils ne poussent pas
je veux tu pousses à l'orge pas comme on
gagne ça je ne sais pas du tout comment
gagner ça mais ok c'est sympa ces petits
sacrifices là c'était le beau jeu quand
même les tontons ça réagit pas dans le
chatt moi je vous fais du sacrifice de
pièces du sacrifice de tours joue
sacrifie tout n'est vous n'êtes pas là
mais tu t'es pas là mais vous n'êtes pas
là dans le chat un chat calme ou de chez
vous le mec là et comme ils ont peu plus
quoi les mecs
non je ne veux plus jouer cette partie
ça m'intéresse pas en fait je vais faire
kébé 6b quatre matins pour être très
très clair des v6 b4 matin pareil quand
même dans le domaine du sympa miroiter 3
j pal joensen du soir c'est lui ne
regarde pas 1 qu'est ce qui unit valise
est très content et b6 qui avait si
j'aime beaucoup
avec l'idée beghal mais le mec qui est
carrément dix connectés quoi il se dit
non je ne jouerai jamais contre un
joueur qui sacrifie autant je refuse de
jouer contre toi ben alors que c'était
très sympa ce qu'on a fait c'était le
beau jeu c'était quand même le beau jeu
de chez le beau je regardais les mecs
quand même pas je vous remontre pour le
mec le mec bon le mec il est là ah bon
il chasse le fou on va dégage avec ton
pionsat nous intéresse pas et maintenant
broc bon les mecs fait refouler 3 poule
k et c5 et là tout d'un coup on attaque
tout quoi son cahier des quatre sont
fous son pion enfin tout d'un coup il
n'existe plus oui la feda me sens car on
dégage avec ton cavaliers dont les tours
c'est de la merde c en est au courant il
revient hop je remets une autour et puis
là il ya carrément sacrifier la lame est
ce que je vais lui faire en fait s'il
bouge et ça comme ça je voulais lui
sacrifier encore des trucs dessus
enfin je sais pas si c'était bon mais je
voulais balance et je sais pas peut-être
une tour encore mais il aurait
probablement pu faire pousser un moment
et je me serais retrouvé enfin genre à
faire une variante de ce type là en
bronze
vous ment sur le cloud agences et deux
en fait mais je vais lui claquer la tour
en fait j'ai dit rbo dégagent les tours
c'est de la merde tu n'existes plus
s'arrêter pas mal tout reprend des trois
cas on aurait craqué la tour dessus et
après on aurait joué sur le fait qu ont
cloué le fou est en fête s'y prend on
prend y prend hélas il dit walsh et du
matos et tout en fait par rien du tout
je menace de tomates et tu empêches je
remettais boom tu dégages boom tu
dégages boom tu n'as plus aucune pièce
qui n'existe plus
donc bon c'était pas mal
qu'est ce que tu lui un talent ce petit
bonbon à voir mais je vous jure 1 qu' on
va tomber à un moment donné sur un mec
qui va nous mettre une dérouillée mellal
à notre classement normal ça doit être
23 50 24 maximum je connais un peu de
chasse comme j'ai l'habitude de jouer
dessus je peux vous dire qu'on est très
très très loin de jouer à 2536 mais
genre très très loin c'est je sais pas
ce qui se passe c'est soit le monde
entier qui en pls parce que on est en
mode pleine lune
donc là les mecs sont là c'est la pleine
lune ils n'en peuvent plus soit j'en
sais rien mais c'est complètement
anormal quoi ça ne ce n'est pas possible
et je rentre en g8 qui est très bien
placé sur sa case de départ
je suis beaucoup plus dans l'esprit que
toi et maintenant tu ne joueras page 5
je ne te laisserai jamais joué h5 si tu
veux jouer mais il faut que tu prennes
ap
je reviens par l'afld regarde hop slam
c'est cet été là non je suis là fait
très attention
cavalier quatre volumes est que
s'approche de mon roi bon
bon c'est un peu pénible faut le
reconnaître
parce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
faire grand roque on va complètement le
déstabiliser le mec ne s'y attend pas
ici je vais faire cavalier à six il est
très heureux lui de son côté madame
croyais peut-être je pense qu'on peut
abandonner direct ce soir sans le plus à
ce qui doit arriver quoi quand on joue
aussi mal c'est un peu ce qui doit
arriver mon affaire fuite
d'un projet si sèchement je vais
abandonner maintenant je fabrique les
pros h4 quand même pour le beau jeu mais
avoue prendre 17 donc abandonné mais
voilà ça ressemble plus à ce qui doit
arriver normalement une amélioration due
forme de pénis parce que ça c'est un peu
des parties normales là franchement
c'est complètement le niveau qu'on acer
que je ne vois absolument rien je vous
jure que je vous des parties à s'y fait
j'ai prendrai vraiment dans la merde on
est dans la merde mais c'est vraiment
enfin je dois absolument rien je
comprends juste même pas quand c'est
possible de garder même plus de 2004 en
voyant rien tu prends mon cas je ferai
avec madame dame centralisée dès le
début de la partie
ça me confère un gros avantage toi tu as
dame est encore n'est pas encore sorti
je sors mes plus forte pièce au début de
la partie très très logique là on tombe
sur un os bien le mec va nous sortir
tous les fondamentaux qui haïssez 6
j'attaque la dame je recule pas un genre
je joue deux fois la plus forte pièce à
croire au maintien
hop je la joue une troisième fois déjà
joué trois fois madame je suis
clairement beaucoup mieux que lui enfin
j'ai un fou plein central
je regarde les deux côtés voilà je joue
les mêmes pièces plusieurs fois en début
de partie
concept très important des échecs jouer
vos pièces un maximum de fois en
ouverture les mecs
elle tient kadhafi catésien faut bien
faire france et trois points d'où la
théorie la bible bon alors maintenant
kébé 5 à 7 quand même assez stupide mais
mais d'un autre côté c'est stupide ça va
encore plus envie de le jouer je suis je
suis je suis partagé
saleh après ma c'est con ça donne envie
quoi même ce qui est appliquée et b sont
un peu raides
c'est un peu des notes c'est un peu
dommage c'est un peu perdant mais bon on
va écouter dans la protéger en faisant
que si vous voulez qu'on fasse une
position est très très mauvaise
bon
moi ce que je vais essayer de faire ce
doublé sur la colonne d écouter les amis
on va essayer de doubler sur la colonne
des dons va doubler en fait je je je
prends amis vers québec a tal afar
bah ouais c'est quand même c'est
complètement débile non mais c'est
embêtant quoi bloquer id4 tête manquée
des quatre ça va encore
moi j'ai pas il peut faire fou prend
prises et a déjà une très bonne finale
mais bon vu comment on joue il doit se
demander qu'est ce que je peux obtenir
de plus elle je fais pas du coup j'ai
hâte à tourteron j'avais envie
d'attaquer depuis tout à l'heure
ouais j'attaque une deuxième fois
non en fait je vais en profiter pour
prendre et pour revenir en a trois
cavaliers sur le bord très très fort
c'est cesser complètement la case à 3
c'est la cas ce que je visais depuis le
début de la partie alors je m'étais raté
en développement de cavaliers puis vous
si je pouvais mettre en a trois je serai
bien même un jeu mêlant c4 je me recycle
fessé 5 je viens à eux trois je fais
toutes les cases de l'échiquier je fais
un tour de cavalli avec mon cavalier
fait très attention à ce que tu vas
faire au prochain coup là je suis chaud
patate là j'étais complètement mystifié
quand le mec s'est fait mystifier et une
finale complètement lieu et il s'est
fait mystifier bon jeu solidifiait se
solidifie
moi j'ai parfois j'ai senti que c'était
une connerie solidifier moi je vais
attaquer je vais me paraît avec ça la
semi mystifié camon ces autos mystifié
derrière ok bon moi je vais réattaquer
ça quand même fait très attention tout
va dégager comme la fable se fout de
m'intéresse pas je ne suis pas du tout
intéressé par ce fou je lui mystifié son
fiancé 5
enfin je vais te faire ces trois buts
encaissés ton pions je vais avoir un
trois contre et enfin quelle chance tu
vas faire flamber 5
sur ce je peux faire c'est 3 encaissé
son pion mais bon on verra on verra ce
que je fais je ne dis pas à mes coups
mais en fait non je t'attaque ton foot y
en a mais il peut prendre et prend des
airs de haye ne le voit pas très bien
c'est un niveau de jeu quand même très
déplorable on ne voit pas les prises et
à et vous prendrez trois fous problème
de norme est ok mais je sais pas ses
failles et une histoire de lune là c'est
pas possible
non mais franchement enfin c'est enfin
je veux dire je veux pas être
complètement lunaire comme mec mais
meillard y ait un problème de lune on
peut pas être aussi nul que ça enfin je
veux dire on joue tous très très mal que
moi jouent mal encore j'ai envie de vous
dire on a l'habitude mais lui là le mec
enfin il a rien demandé on l a réussi à
me choper un pion et doit être content
mais mais mais mais c'est affreux le
niveau de jeu vraiment les gens c'est
pas que moi pour une fois quand c'est
moi encore je dis bon c'est normal
maintenant il va me faire il va me faire
à quatre il va me fixe est mince et
maintenant ils à roye là ouais je fais
n'importe quoi j'ai donné tous mes pions
alors que je veux les et une bonne
finale j'aurais jamais dû la perdre ça
là mais bon
même le truc c'est que lui a très mal
joué aussi donc truc c'est que lui a
très très très mal joué aussi donc on
peut rien dire non plus jusqu'au bout il
joue mal c'est pas comme si un peu mal
joué au début et puis qu'après ils
s'étaient calmées
qu'est-ce que même ça en fait ça gagner
pas à la fin si je vais cavalli a fuité
tout même sa saga n'y est pas mais c'est
complètement dingue franchement enfin
dans un côté ce stream est assez marrant
je vous jure que c'est pas pour rigoler
j'ai jamais vu que ça a joué aussi mal à
ce niveau et l'eau en fait franchement
genre mais vraiment jamais jamais jamais
jamais de ma vie à chaque fois qu'ils
montent à 2005 c'est que je suis assez
en forme et que ça joue assez bien mais
là franchement j'aurais même dû mal à
tenir 2004 où 23 50
c'est vraiment la première fois que je
vois ça du coup c'est marrant à partager
de partager ça avec vous ça change en
fait et c'est vraiment un pur style quoi
c'est vraiment faire samsung c'est des
mecs que je connais qui joue assez bien
ce mec là je joue contre lui je vois
c'est bien là la dernière bon jeu le
perdu parce qu'on fait vraiment
n'importe quoi mais en gros si je la
gagne c'est pareil
et franchement ça aurait pas été mérité
autant là il me domine quand même dans
l'ouverture ce que je fais des
ouvertures un peu n'importe quoi et ça
lui va peut-être gagner proprement à
précédente cependant c'est quand même
assez dingue
avec g et si cette fois ci mais bon j'ai
pas très convaincu par son nom en fait
tu vas faire fou ici et je veux faire
même foule à très mauvais en fait fait
il ya ce pion qui reste en prix sans
arrêt en fait c'est très très mauvais un
truc qui va pas du tout dans mon
ouverture en fait
je mets genre qu'il va pas du tout du
tout quoi
j'aimais à tour en acheter deux
protéines qui arrive cette non j'avais
pas le temps de prendre le pyongyang 59
c'est pas à moi de jouer en fait là
l'ouverture complètement ratée dangereux
la reperdre mais franchement c'est
ça peut être une partie marrante pour
nous on est juste très très mal
ok on va ramener la dame là bas donc il
manque la dame en a cinq ok je suis pas
confiant
évidemment ce qu'il en reste dur mais je
suis content parce que je protège des
trucs sur la cinquième rang j'ai donc je
me dis à la rigueur on sait par le fasb
s'ils sont à se barrer à faire ces cinq
bombes ces cinq c'est vraiment pourri en
fait parce que j'ai pas vu mais j'ai des
problèmes sur la huitième rang j'ai en
fait j'aime à tour qui en arrache cette
non mais c'est affreux
oui c'est complètement nul en fait ce
que j'ai fait
donc je peux tenter un truc genre je
prends il prend et je vais prendre là et
je cloud son pion b
ok je vais prétendre que ça tient
je pensais très mauvais mais quelle
chance d'avoir ça quand même ok là il a
ça qui lui aussi un peu chanceux
du coup bouger le fou ça me tente pas
trop je vais tenter ça ça
même en fait c'est mauvais bon j'ai
tenté quand même
je pense et ce qui m'offre les
meilleures chances pratique en fait mais
c'est mauvais si à faire froid ces deux
airois des deux noms il vient là bas du
coup je vais faire dame ses trois échecs
et je vais choquer son pion là bas sont
fous là j'ai loupé son fou irish chope
matour ouais bah mince j'aurais dû faire
madame échec encore une fois qu'est ce
que c'est mal joué
qu'est ce que c'est mal joué du coup on
est foutu affaire d'âme ses 2 c'est fini
je comprends vraiment pas pourquoi il
prend autant de temps en fait
honnêtement je ne comprends rien c'est
hyper dur a commenté en fait ce que j'ai
l'impression que je ne suis pas le seul
à faire du cac à ça ce que j'avais vu
direct en fait ce qu'il a fait
d'où mon étonnement qu'il n'ait pas joué
plus vite angers une micro idc qu'à la
tour là-bas emprise mais s'il fait tout
et je suis très mal ou d'amis ici
éventuellement mettre la dame là on va
essayer de repas c'est comme ça je vais
prendre mais j'ai essayé de passer là
mais en fait il est mal autant en plus
c'est dommage on va encore va peut-être
encore juste mourir quelques centièmes
de seconde
kemin ci fait tourbe est un jeu le match
quoi kevin vient là je fais chaque jeu
fait échec fait chèque et tout raciste
et je suis gagnant en fait mais juste
j'ai pas le temps incroyable un groupe
comme je disais si fils incroyable pour
58 dam des cas tous y avait peut-être
des trucs un pur pour gagner avant est
possible mais c'est juste impression en
2006 sent le mec quand même
c'est quand même assez incroyable j'ai
encore raté mon ouverture en plusieurs à
tout mais ouverture
bonjour à tous ce que je fais mais bon
les hommages une question de question de
temps quoi nous a un peu manqué non je
serai un peu plus monter à 25 50 ans je
vais peut-être les pires échecs
autant quand je jouais contre magnus
c'est le jour où je jouais le milieu de
ma vie à toi c'est des pires journées ça
faisait très longtemps que mais bon ça
montre que vous voyez finalement
finalement on peut ça vous fait pas un
démon de ce classement en fait c'est pas
ben voilà si vous suivez le stream
j'espère que ça vous motive un jour au
contraire donc là ok bon le truc c'est
que d'habitude la dame n'est pas en d2
opposition mais là n'est pas si mal
placé
ça ferait du cavalier à 3 comme ça j'en
serais fou b5 ok il n'empêche ça s'est
assez bien joué il force à prendre et je
vais faire rock mais comme ça il aura la
case d3 pour son fou il peut me faire un
petit tour des huit au passage c'est pas
mal ça va la vie avec son fou là et puis
après il va venir me gênait quoi donc
ils enchaînent ils modifient créé pas
mal de menaces et son fou bien installé
freixe pas s'il va prendre angers 5 ou
pas voilà qu'il prend pour une revanche
est né un petit peu plus tôt à aller
vers h3 comme ça je reviendrai vers f4
au cas où le cas échéant ce que six
jeunes en f3 il me faisait peut-être
foucades quoi que j'aurais pu faire
caïds et deux complètement mais bon là
au moins je faire cavalier f4
sarah grand-chose truc c'est que sur
cavaliers prend il à me faire pions
prends je vais mettre le cavalier en
déduit commencer par tele2 je me garder
l'option
je pense que je dois prendre je vais
faire b4 hockey vraiment y'a rien de
toute façon sur mon pion à h2o et comme
celle ci prend je prends et encore est
ce que je suis vraiment content d'avoir
pris à j'en sais rien je sais pas je
n'arrive pas trop évalué j'aime pas
croire le pion détroit moment je joue
vite une fois juge jouer vite ça me
suffit à être pas mal fin je mériterai
de la gagner celle là franchement je
mérite de la gagner
fr damas 3g pas trop peur de son attaque
pour le moment je me ferai toujours g3
au pire cavaliers f1 il est encore loin
de me matter s'il me prend la tête je
veux prendre là bas là bas
bon du coup j'ai bien envie de le faire
tomber dans celle là ok bon il veut
créer des menaces vous savez quoi
j'ai pas envie de m'embêter mais alors
du tout ok pour moi ça va jamais matté
son truc qu'est ce que j'ai raté
ok j'ai raté ça
c'est joli ce truc là j'ai pas vu du
tout je savais que j'avais raté un truc
mais j'avais pas à quoi bon ben ok que
faire dommage sinon on aurait gagné
cette partie mais du coup on est obligé
de sacrifier et on va de nouveau perdre
mais j'aurais dû faire g3 commises et
mon instinct mais bon
j'avais envie de voir ce que j'avais
raté bon ben j'ai juste fait j'ai trois
on aurait gagné quel idiot on va voir ça
la met you c'est plutôt normal qu'on
repère notre classement même si c'est
pas méga mérité sur ces parties là
5 si je suis en forme et que je suis
tombé sur des adversaires comme ça je
pourrais éventuellement monter au lait
2006 son visa bhl quoi si les mecs
jouent comme ça je peux viser les 2006
sur chaise comme comme je vous dis c'est
quand même pas fameux fameux et je sens
que j'ai prennent beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de marge par rapport à leur
niveau actuel
donc ça pourrait le faire
je déplacés ont couvert c'est celle qui
sera mieux placé
j'ai pas trop ce qu'il veut faire en
fait je veux faire courber un machin bas
ok je peux être qu'heureux ans est en
fait le truc c'est d'affaires tour live
à me prendre le pion à 7 c'est
complètement stupide ce que je veux
c'est complètement idiot non mais
j'arrive vraiment pas à jouer ce soir
c'est honteux je ramenais salah zahaf
c'est tellement une honte je pense pas
cgem un jour non je ne vais même pas
essayé en fait ça ne m'intéresse pas ok
on va prendre je vais y revenir ensuite
avec ma tour oui je sais pas je vais
sacrifier ma tournage trois femmes qui
va gagner madame comme ça fout un bon ok
c'est tellement une honte
guillaume à perdre le pion celles ci
sont à perdre la partie vraiment
bêtement mais ok mais on va maintenant
mais ok là c'est vraiment n'importe quoi
c'est vraiment n'importe quoi mais c'est
ça sa tournée sur les deux trois parties
que j'aurais pu gagner
j'aime pas cette position du tout je
déteste jouer cette position plus
marrant je vais parler avant-hier avec
un de mes élèves
c'est une déposition que je déteste
jouer avec les blancs
les joueurs tous rêvent d un et puis
comme ça je pourrais peut-être faire
flouer fin
qu'elle aime bien mettre mon choix est
fait comme ça et pas mal placé précis
mais ça je vais revenir en b 5 mais qui
ne sait pas quoi faire avec son fou
c'est que je suis en bessin accouchement
b5 n'ont évoqué justifé d'amd 8 comme ça
je fais tour d un ben je sais pas du
tout où il va aller avec sa dame s'y
vend aussi ceux du pouce des cinq au
passage comme ça je vais taper à 7,6
violence et cette violence et avec la
tour je serai heureux non mais là pour
une fois enfin jusqu'ici pas vraiment ça
va
qui ayant des six
c'est venir vers b6 psg fouet f4
je m'entoure en c1 pour le moment est
peut-être à venir vers b4 aussi master
pas mal joué ce truc à moi je reviens en
f1 je ne fais que des va-et-vient
taillefer b5 maintenant s est possible
ce serait d'ailleurs très bien joué moi
je vais en profiter refaire faut être
quatre ou cinq mois si ce bar comme ça
/ photo 5 faire casser si une tête je
peux prendre prendre que j'ai une
intuition pour ça je réalise ici je
prends af à toute façon je gagnais une
pièce en un coup de mains ok mais quand
je vois pas que je suis vraiment désolé
mais c'est hyper dur de commenter quand
je vois pas que je me laisse de gagner
une pièce en un coup c'est vraiment
difficile
je ne vois pas je ne vois juste pas les
menaces primaire de mes coups en fait
c'est très très très très déstabilisant
près de voyez pas que j'aimerais c'est
juste de gagner une pièce pour vous
expliquer et ça c'est hyper
déstabilisant quand vous jouer aux
échecs et que hockey du coup la banque
il prend des quatre marche pas du tout
reprend ses 8 cf 3 kg 2 mais c'est très
difficile en fait parce que dès que je
calcule un truc qui peut avoir une
grosse erreur tactique mais vraiment
grosse et des jours comme ça on est
capable de rater des trucs très très
très très simple donc si ça vous arrive
aussi stressé pas mais justement ça
rende ça rend vraiment la tâche de jouer
aux échecs très complexe qui est
vraiment il n'ya toujours pas ce truc là
parce que maintenant il voir là bas et
ça je voulais faire tour ses 500 km
alentour c1
pas monter le roi
ok du coup on va apprendre comprendre et
faire voilà et ça c'est nul
que j'ai peur de me faire fixer les
pions je vais faire à 3 je veux pas me
faire fixer les pions via b 5 b 4 que ça
c'est bien joué de sa part
donc on va proposer nul façon c'est nul
ce truc là mais bon il va refuser
l'essai nous jouer autant il aura raison
même si c'est complètement nul il a
raison nous jouer autant pourquoi pas le
faire on aurait fait pareil on va pas
critiquer les gens qui font comme nous
quand même ce serait le comble si moi je
met à critiquer les gens qui va lui
faire qu'ils veulent faire tomber
franchement où va-t-on je ne me
permettrais pas s'est passé derrière sa
chaîne de pyongyang
on va tenter de la gagner parce que
sinon on va perdre à petit feu autant
nous on va essayer d'aller jouer de ce
côté là
aya cavaliers c3 j'étais sûr qu'on
serait piégé sur une fourchette débile
mais on était plus ou moins obligé de
tenter sa non c'est pas si facile pour
lui de se dépatouiller je pense qu'elle
assiste à un mauvais coup peut-être on
peut encore la tenir à deux on peut
encore la tenir
on aurait éventuellement pu la tenir
mais j'aurais pu la tenir si je m'étais
pas trompé à ce moment là en pré mouvant
fallait faire f4 l'a peut-être f4 ouais
ça tenait il devait faire comprend en
plus on prend cavaliers prend est prise
ok pour moi j'ai pas pris de temps
j'aurais peut-être pu prendre le pion à
un moment donné j'ai juste dû rater en
fait
mais oui c'est jouer autant ce truc là
si on avait eu assez temps l'aurait on
l'aurait tenu lui vite
ok ça je me rappelle pas en fait qu'est
ce qui se passe là dessus je ça me dit
quelque chose
non ok mais c'est pas la première fois
qu'on joue ça en fait juste après une
fois j'avais pas compris le truc ce truc
doit exister
apparemment c'est théorique je connais
pas juste
poussé au quai je vais pousser pousser
il prend je faire b4 bon ok
ok simek menés 16-0 ça quand même faire
beaucoup malgré que la plupart des
partis se sont vraiment joué à rien
dans la dernière c'était vraiment c'est
vraiment jouer autant mais bon c'est
mérité d'un autre côté mais sûrement
juste pas cette variante fait les mecs
largue un pion mais je vois pas je
prends pas troller
enfin je vois qu'il ya de l'activité
mais juste quand même lampions quoi
c'est un poil optimiste
c'est être un poil optimiste de ma part
pas mal de trucs attaquer
un tas de trucs attaqué ras
je veux de ma tour en a cinq
ces merdes bis zum et vous écrivant lui
mais c'est sûr tout à fait tu as tout à
fait raison je leur vends parce que je
calcule lentement aujourd'hui que là
mais bon je veux pas me sur eux répéter
ok bon je sais pas quoi jouer juste
aucune idée - faire caillasser 5 tu vas
faire classer 4ème et à tour prend ici
non mais c'est ça le truc c'est que je
rate trop de coups simples comme ça mais
genre trop trop trop obligés de revenir
là et on est complètement foutue
maintenant bon ça c'est pas une tour en
un coup qui émeut les dites pas qu'il un
truc avec fois-çi ce qui marche quand
même
non non
ça du coup ça doit être gagnant en 1/4
une pièce de plus la messe pas si simple
que ça a gagné à cause du temps une
nouvelle fois j'aime pas du tout mais
trois sur quatre noirs mais bon c'est
fait c'est fait qu'à faire qu'il y avait
quatre échecs comme ça on va les forcer
à prendre ça
demain problème c'est que
c'est exactement ça c'est qu'on a plus
de temps une nouvelle fois même si la
position est très bonne
il va nous arnaquer
pas du tout en fait ah ouais maintenant
il ya ça bref voilà on sait encore faire
un accueil une position gagnante en
jouant très mal non mais je vous dis
j'arrive juste pas aujourd'hui c'est
juste pas possible
et c'est d'autant plus frustrant en fait
bon avoir une dernière mais c'est
d'autant plus frustrant en fait de
perdre comme ça quand on a des bonnes
positions parce que là vraiment on avait
de nouveau une pièce de plus et tout ça
est enfin c'est juste une défaite une
des fat ridicule si on gagne 4,3 ce
match contre ce mec là c'est juste pas
volé quoi c'est pas du tout un massacre
à ni rien c'est que des positions
également le mec arnaque au temps où là
je sais pas on fait des heures sup id je
ne sais pas quoi faire
c'est vraiment que tu essaieras con
comme ça tout le temps mais ok mais ces
indiens m'aiment relou quoi
bon essai de finir par une victoire ça
quand même une bonne chose
c'est quand même assez créé quand je
souhaite motive je crois je crois le
problème c'est que je perdais le web et
que je fasse un peu n'importe quoi ça me
motiver
marqueurs avoir essayé de
mais c'est de finir par une victoire
mais franchement le cas et qu'on a perdu
comme on a perdu ça ça comme on le perd
foi je ne sais pas comment on fait pour
perdre tous ces trucs là rien faire qui
a aidé quatre noms on peut pas
qu'est-ce que si on trouve juste nul ils
acceptent d'être inintéressant à jouer
au possible mais bon ok mais ne veut pas
faire nul
quelle catastrophe si tu ne veux pas
faire du monde est dans la merde
d'ailleurs on est en train de la perdre
petit à petit qu'est-ce que je joue mal
ce qu'on va être b5 ça va être très
mauvais mais c'est juste un florilège
d'erreurs mais bon
nate est temps de faire qui est des 3 b
5e je sais pas moi ok on n'a pas du tout
le temps de le faire mais qu'on va
prendre à faire h3 on va faire quelle
idée 3 et je sais pas on va essayer de
se sauver
on va essayer de jouer tempo allez on va
essayer de faire quelque chose à
l'attaqué le fou qui on va chasser on
avec le foot et 5 ha non en fait je ne
peux pas le faire non armés au kef cours
- est-ce que je vois pas que je peux pas
possible qu'il faut que je fasse apprend
apprend et c5
c'est juste un jeu
donc elles vont ranger deux et peut-être
que faire une espèce de forteresse
je vais peut-être cet argent en
forteresse
mais je trouve pas trop comment là je
suis en train de mettre ça là
tu vas mettre comme ça et puis touche à
rien est-ce qu'on peut finir par une
forteresse où est ce que ça ne va pas
marcher
faire ça comme ça
je sais pas si mon cas va se faire
enfermer un moment donné
j'ai l'impression qu'ils se fait
enfermer à une cavale
mais ils sont enfermés écoutez c'est pas
le bon jour écoutant vallée du lot
je vais me reposer je vais aller dormir
un petit peu et ce sera mieux la
prochaine fois parce que là c'est
vraiment n'importe quoi
bon on a perdu 8 0 mais franchement
c'était tellement n'importe quoi les
partis de a à z qu'on aura notre notre
revanche plus tard mais j'aurais
sûrement dû sortir avec mon cavalier via
bbc 6 des 4 et voilà
bon je vous souhaite bonne soirée à tous
baidu passe super bien du tout
captain rinne joue vraiment pas bien du
tout je t'assure que ce mec-là est pas
super fort du tout mais bon c'est comme
ça
allez bonne soirée tout le monde chars